I have metastatic breast cancer in my lungs and lung lighting. And I'm having it a difficult time
to breathe due to the large number of tumors. Do you have any suggestions like rife programs
or essential oils? So the rife program that you're doing is the one I created for the breast cancer.
So when cancer metastasizes, remember that it's metastasizing as that same cancer just because it's
in the lungs, it's not lung cancer. It's still breast cancer. So we all understand that.
So you're still running the breast cancer frequencies to not tell the cancer. That's going to be the
best thing to help with those tumors that are in the lung is to run the cancer frequencies that I
created. But there's nothing wrong with running symptom type frequencies if you have time.
So during the day, I'm having a hard time breathing, I'm just sitting relaxing. Can I experiment with
some other frequencies? Absolutely. One issue that is not uncommon when cancer metastasizes to the
lung is to have a comorbidity of an infection. So a person can develop a pneumonia that is separate
from the cancer. It's not cancer. It's pneumonia because of the diminished immune response in the
area. So I would run, if I were this person asking this question, and I had time during the day,
I would run the pneumonia blaster frequency. There's a frequency alphabetically. It's called
pneumonia blaster. I think that's the best pneumonia program. Just to make sure there's not a comorbidity
of pneumonia, how would you know? How would you know if I have a pneumonia or not? Well, typically a
plain view chest x-ray. So just an x-ray, another MRI or not a CT scan, a plain film chest x-ray,
would be able to show a pneumonia if that's the case. Then I don't think I have pneumonia. I went
to the doctor, did an x-ray, it wasn't pneumonia. Okay, well then maybe don't run that program. But if
you do notice that you have any acute loss of lung capacity, you have to be careful about it acute
pneumonia. So acute pneumonia is in be common to break out and be an issue as a comorbidity with
any cancer that has metastasized to the lung. Other than you could do inflammation,
you could do other infectious programs, you could run
your best thing besides those would be the just your short program cancer program. You've got to
knock the cancer down to ultimately get better. If the difficulty breathing is due to the tumors
that it's the cancer program that would be best, if the difficulty breathing is due to
comorbidity of an infection, then an infection program would be in order. Other things to do, the
supplements that I recommended, yes, essential oils, yes, that you could use essential oils.
Remember, essential oils are pretty strong, so be careful how much you use the essential.
And then doing a nebulizer, we have the formula for nebulizing colloidal silver, or excuse me,
hydrogen peroxide. On the member side, on the home page, Dr. Bacola's formula for
nebulizing hydrogen peroxide is available for you to download as a PDF.